Women have, what's lovingly referred to as a biological clock.
Don't you think you should have kids soon?  Because like if you have kids around
here it could be bad for your body
*alarm clock ringing*
It's basically this pressure that's looming over our heads
that says "if you want to have a baby, there's a deadline.
Or else there are serious health consequences."
But as I get older, I'm like not really sure if I even want kids.
I mean, I have 4 cats and right now that's kind of enough.
Four cats, no cuddles.  This is parenthood.
I also run a business and I want to establish my career.
Seriously, get me my lunch.
Plus, I'm like not even married yet.  Not even close.
Hey babe?
Babe.
Babe!
Can you come here?
Please?
I want to talk to you.
Part of me thinks like, not having kids is the more responsible thing to do anyway.
I mean our Earth is so overpopulated.  And if I want
to be a parent later in life, maybe I should just adopt
one of the thousands of orphaned children who are looking for loving parents.
Hi.  Yes, I'm ready to be a mom now so I'll go ahead and take 4 of your most unfortunate orphans.
But then another part of me chimes in:
"well what about pregnancy?  That seems like a magical awesome process of life
that you want to experience and like bring a part of you into the world.
*vomiting*
And then some smaller part of me is like
"Well, maybe I'll just be a multiple cat momma forever."
Please cuddle with me.  Please care about me!
Congress!  Congress!
But then again, you know, when I'm in my 30s, I may feel completely
differently about all of these things.
And I don't mind taking that long to really consider it.
Like, I have always wanted to get a tattoo
but I told myself "You can't get a tattoo until you want the same one for 10 years straight."
And right now I'm on year 5 of maybe still wanting that same tattoo.
So if I'm taking this long to consider ink on my skin permanently
it's fine that I'm going to take this long to think about bringing another
human being into the world through my vagina
and just destroying my body and potentially staying up every night after then
having to raise another human being and not like fuck it up.
What do you think?  Do you want kids?
Are you going to adopt a couple of cats and call it a day?
Are you adopted and was it like the best thing ever?
Let me know.
I'm Anna Akana.  Stay awesome Gotham.